boa tarde a todos é essa vamos falar
sobre educação
então queria começar essa nossa conversa
com essa imagem
essa imagem é uma uma gravura do século
14.300 alguma coisa está exposta na
universidade de bolonha
uma das versões mais antigas que estão
ativas no mundo está sendo exposta nessa
ela esta gravura eu queria chamar a
atenção esta gravura para algumas
semelhanças com o modelo pedagógico que
a maior parte das escolas trabalha hoje
em dia então e essa você tem 700 anos
esta gravura e queria que vocês procuram
identificar um professor falando no
púlpito
nós temos aqui uma turminha da frente
muito interessada prestando atenção
copiando a matéria
temos aqui uma turma do fundão
conversando batendo papo dizer né que
temos aqui um camarada domingo né
é então essa é aquela que tem 700 anos
gente 600 e 700 anos é uma metodologia
pedagógica em que o professor falou os
alunos que copiam ea maior parte das
nossas escolas seja com com nível que
for trabalha com essa metodologia ou
seja nós repetimos um modelo pedagógico
que tem 700 anos ou mais
é o chamado modelo medieval o modelo
escolástico é e muita gente diz o
seguinte vamos superar esse modelo
vamos construir um modelo pedagógico em
que o aluno não fique passivo na sala de
aula em que o aluno participe ativamente
que ele seja o agente do seu dos da
construção do conhecimento essa esse
discurso da substituição do modelo
pedagógico medieval por um sistema mais
dinâmico é muito comum um sentido é isso
é tido como um modelo mais inovador o
modelo mais arrojado e que eu gosto de
conversar com vocês é que esse modelo
dita inovador ele não é inovador
ele é mais antigo do que o modelo
anterior isso vão achar isso mas
sócrates 2.500 anos aquele modelo foi de
700 anos 2000 anos o modelo escolástico
o medieval mas o modelo socrático o
modelo grego o modelo clássico tem 2.500
anos esse que se caracterize em que
perguntas sócrates nunca respondi a ele
sempre devolve a pergunta do seu aluno
com uma outra pergunta e através desse
processo e sucessivas perguntas e
estabelecer um diálogo
surgiu um método dialético também
chamada de maio indica que era a
metodologia de sócrates grega
então nós temos aí dois tipos de
metodologia a metodologia bem antiga que
é socrática e uma metodologia mais
recente uma metodologia medieval baseada
na preleção e há um conflito entre essas
duas metodologias ok grave nesse ponto
vamos pra esse ponto aqui agora vocês
observassem essa escultura a belíssima
peça exposta na basílica são pretos eles
são pedro a pietá de michelângelo todos
conhecem michelangelo
esse é um novo bloco de mármore então e
já foi atirando as outras pedrinhas e
até chegar nisso ele vivia antes ele só
tinha os outros que estavam na frente e
chegou nessa belíssima peça agora queria
que se observasse também essa outra peça
belíssima também belíssimo
só que muito mais antiga é do século
antes de cristo de de esculturas e que
provavelmente vocês não conhecem pouca
gente conhece o autor dessa dessa peça
também está exposta no museu do vaticano
na itália também belíssima peça também
que é preciso observar assim à
semelhança da estética das duas peças
elas temos separadas em 1600 anos mas
tem uma estética muito parecida ou seja
porque me que lamy elogiou depois né
porque michelangelo copiou uma estética
anterior
este é o renascimento porque nós porque
não é nascimento porque é renascimento é
renascimento por que por que volta ao
que volta à grécia antiga o modelo
clássico vai se inspirar na estética
grega ea partir daquilo vai fazer uma
manifestação no caso uma manifestação
artística então renascer no conceito do
renascimento é buscar inspiração na
grécia antiga se fala de renascimento em
várias áreas em várias outras áreas
também com a gente fala da música por
exemplo a música clássica é uma
manifestação que não é nessa época não é
no século 15 temos documento temporal
dos 200 300 anos música beethoven 1837
1901 1971 e 18 nos 300 anos de diferença
dá do renascimento da arte da da
escultura no caso então é o movimento do
renascimento movimento
voltar num mundo grego buscar inspiração
mas não necessariamente na mesma época e
engraçado que não existe esse conceito
na educação apesar do fenômeno existe o
que muitos educadores fazem hoje um
renascimento
nós vamos voltando ao modelo grego como
uberlândia voltou como como músico no
japão voltou como propor não diria mas
bah como ba voltou a gente vai encontrar
vários vários apps pensadores vamos
encontrar em convênios com o suor de um
diu e curso inclusive através de um
livro famoso deles chamado e milho ele
dizia exatamente isso que o aluno que
deve construir o seu conhecimento daí a
gente pode se dizer que o que o som dos
precursores do construtivismo vamos
encontrar isso em cuba está nem maria
montessori vygotsky piaget todos eles
falando sobre a mesma coisa e não só não
só em outros países no brasil também
vamos encontrar aí fernanda azevedo
anísio teixeira paulo freire rubem alves
todos esses fala uma coisa comum em que
o aluno deve ser o agente da produção de
seu próprio conhecimento grego socrático
não escolástico não medieval muito bem
então temos aí uma discussão se hoje não
somos em alguma conferência educacional
nós vamos encontrar essa discussão
sempre presente muitos muitos falam
sobre isso é muito charmoso muito sexy
um dia assim conversar sobre isso mas
tem um problema nessa discussão porque
essa discussão ela o predomínio dessa
discussão de qual modelo deve ser o céu
escolástico o seu medieval oculta ou
abafa uma outra discussão igualmente
importante que a discussão que uma
discussão que não é tão sexy num dia
assim que a discussão das metodologias
educacionais como é que eu faço o aluno
aprender como a gente faz efetivamente
ele tem que ler ele tem que fazer
trabalho em grupo e tem que fazer prova
de texto e fazer prova dissertativa ele
tem que sentar na frente que senta atrás
que são procedimentos muito mais
operacionais do dia a dia e por não
serem tão charmosos onde assim não têm
espaço nas conferências educacionais a
gente discute muito a filosofia eu não
tenho absolutamente nada contra disse eu
adoro o estudo isso eu e me interesso
muito por esses temas mas não pode haver
um predomínio então se vocês olharem
esse gráfico que nós vamos encontrar aí
é o desempenho do brasil nessa prova que
chamar que pisa exame será aplicado nos
alunos
a educação básica a prova de português
de línguas em uma prova de matemática ea
gente vê o resultado do brasil aí ele
está muito atrás de países eu não falar
estados unidos e da europa no dia
seguinte mas vietnã costa rica méxico
uruguai poxa vida da gente a gente tem
que ser mais competitivo e olha que 2012
não foi um ano bom no pisa nos anos
anteriores foi pior ainda então para mim
é difícil dizer qual é a causa disso daí
tem várias causas mas pra mim eu acho
que é uma causa importante que é
exatamente essa que houve uma desculpa
uma ênfase muito grande a discussão mais
filosófica do processo educacional do
que na na questão mas procedural na
questão mais mas mais objetiva e é
interessante porque academia gosta da
ciência defende a ciência e ciência tem
método só que a academia não usa a
ciência nas suas próprias entranhas
ela não usa celular próprio método
científico para dizer o que funciona eo
que não funciona que existe método fazer
isso mas existem pesquisadores que fazem
isso estudiosos que testam que comparam
metodologias e provam que esta funciona
aquela não funciona isso principalmente
nos últimos 20 anos tem aparecido
bastante os resultados da neurociência
da psicologia da aprendizagem que o novo
campo que precisa ser mais o mais
observado não tanto o aspecto filosófico
o histórico mas o aspecto de científico
ea ciência
chegou a quatro conclusões importantes
com relação ao aprendizado que eu
gostaria de destacar que os quatro
conclusões
a primeira com relação à memorização e
então essa discussão que existe o
aspecto filosófico baniu a memorização
então se isso aquilo não pode ignorar o
aluno tem que saber mobilizar o
conhecimento né e é mais ou menos isso
né gente ele tem que aprender alguma
coisa tem que decorar alguma coisa você
imagina o senhor teve um palestrante que
antecedeu a equipe foi teve um enfarte
se imagina e ele está ele está na mesa
da cirurgia o time já estava operando
ele escreveu vasco santana e washington
que esse mesmo tempo ele já tomei aquele
jogo que não pode pois tem que saber
o piloto está levantando o vôo começa a
piscar maluzinha e falei que aquela luz
nem pega o manual a limpeza não é tem
que saber então existem enquanto
aumentam memorização isso achava
importante recente não há
a ação não pode ser banida ela é
importante é preciso que haja a
memorização dentro de um contexto dentro
de uma realidade não decorar por decorar
é que a palavra decorar
ela tem uma conotação subjetiva mas se
você troca decorar pormenorizar a
situação é diferente mas cá pra nós é a
mesma coisa tudo depende do contexto
segundo achado importante
existem técnicas existem métodos que
funcionam e métodos que não funcionam
então é possível aprender a aprender
técnicas que que mostram como o que é é
com efetivo pode ser o aprendizado
então o sul mas acontece que o maior
parte dos programas de capacitação do
professor de formação de professor não
discuti muito essas técnicas não há
espaço para essas técnicas então na
educação fundamental se a gente vai nos
cursos de licenciatura muitas vezes que
forma os professores da educação básica
e não há muito espaço é muito muito
espaço para discussão filosófica que
volta a atacar eu acho superimportante
eu gosto e isso tudo isso mas não pode
ser só isso tem que ter espaço para essa
discussão - sexy - assim mais mais
procedural então eu acho que e quando a
gente fala de educação básica ea gente
informe os professores do curso
licenciatura têm pouco espaço para isso
quando a gente vai pra educação superior
a situação é muito pior porque os
professores educação superior se for
mestrado e doutorado e mestrado tudo
aprendi nada disso nada nem filosófica
também não tem nada disso a aprender
sobre outra coisa - como da aula
então eu acho que existe uma questão
importante aí
uma terceira questão muitas técnicas são
contra intuitivas
então assim eu tenho um exemplo é o
seguinte muitos professores contam
pergunta se você gosta de ler e
sublinhar o livro enquanto lê
muita gente faz isso aí subir enquanto
lê perguntas e isso é bom pra mim é bom
não é pra você é bom você recomendaria
que os alunos fizessem isso também vai
estragar os livros mesmo quesito sair
mas é você recomendaria que os seus
alunos fizessem isso pra aprender mais
aí alguns falam eu acho que se eu acho
que não mas foi bom pra mim é chata e
ciência gente ciência que é um grupo que
faz tem um grupo controle que não faz
aplica a mesma prova e quem aprendeu
mais isso a ciência tem que comparar sem
ver resultados é que vale a pena subir
não vale a pena sublinhar
um e os só que os estudiosos fizeram os
estudos há estudos que provam eu tenho
tempo pesquisando tudo exatamente isso
eles sublinharam adianta
não adianta nada né eu achava que ele
quem encontrou outro estudioso feio
muito feio isso seguinte ele estudou o
efeito de você levar às vezes a bola na
frente da prova
você dá aula ele ler de novo a releitura
também não conseguiu provar que a
releitura tem eficiência como testando o
grupo faz a releitura da aula pra todo
mundo é para em dois grupos não faz
releitura do grupo não faz aplica a
mesma prova ver o resultado e não
conseguiu provar então a gente tem que
ler esses trabalhos científicos estudar
isso produzir novos conhecimentos dentro
dessa lógica científica ao lado da do
lado filosófico porque o lado filosófico
em questões importantes que vou mostrar
que agora que o quarto item esforço
ainda não inventaram com toda tecnologia
uma máquina que um choque na cabeça onde
aprendi ele tem que se esforçar
ele tem que se empenhar não é qualquer
esforço já falei questão da da releitura
é a ler por ler isso não não torna o
aprendizado mais eficiente
mas há mais há um esforço a técnicas que
produzem mais resultado
uma é o seguinte e simples o professor
dá aula papa e pedir para alguém faz uma
pergunta do que acabou de falar então
gente porque vocês acham que com a
diferença que tem entre o método
escolástico meta do goleiro grego método
clássico grego
nessa hora a cabeça vamos começar a
gente que acabou de falar porque não
tava você tem que perguntar alguma coisa
que está quente esse esforço para tentar
achar a resposta que os americanos
chamam de teste é feito esse esforço
produz aprendizado o simples prática
então você está tão interessado na
resposta é interessante que se esforce
para responder isso produz resultados
cientificamente provado e olha só em
socrático e socrático só que ele fazia
isso não tinha ciência então você pode
combinar as duas coisas né quando essa
pergunta é feita uma semana depois da
aula
o efeito é maior ainda no aprendizado
porque ele começou a esquecer
e aí o esforço dele vai ser maior ainda
para lembrar aquilo é chamada de space
linha fat
nós temos experiência em frete e o teste
e fec
dois efeitos são feitos comprovado
cientificamente que produzem resultado
então tem técnicos que produzem técnico
que não produzem se estuda isso e e e cá
pra nós fazer pergunta em sala de aula
ou tem dificuldade nenhuma tem
dificuldades se você imaginar o seguinte
eu tenho uma sala com 50 alunos 60 anos
70 alunos como é que eu vou fazer isso
eu vou perguntar para 50 60 70 alunos
uma vez que consegui aquilo
sei lá vamos avaliar o resultado possa
levantar a mão como é que eu como é que
a gente faz isso aí é uma questão
bastante importante
sócrates não tinha isso celular que a
agecopa também não tinha isso daí o selo
celulares que muitas salas de aula são
banidos ea gente é uma realidade que que
é bastante complicada porque todo mundo
usa celular hoje ele pode ser uma aliada
ele dos professores trabalharem contra o
celular e foi trabalhar com o celular a
favor como faço o que faço a pergunta
mas os alunos respondem no celular e
através do celular você consegue coletar
toda aquela resposta mesmo uma turma de
50 60 70 anos nas salas e aí você vai
coletar aquelas respostas ela lá isso
não existia antes só pra existir pra só
você vai coletar essas respostas e você
vai fazer aquela pergunta e você vai
dizer o seguinte poxa 90% do pessoal
aprendeu vou seguir adiante ou então 30%
não aprendeu
só 30% setor aí não tem como explicar
mas não se espera chegar ao fim do ano o
fim do semestre para chegar à conclusão
precisamos aprender não se pode fazer
isso aula à aula usando um método
socrático clássico renascentista
seja lá o nome que a gente quiser dar
uma base filosófica base científica
através da tecnologia
agora vejo o seguinte eu falei eu vou
adiante e aqueles 10% ficou para trás e
não aprender isso também uma outra
questão que vai revolucionar
completamente a sala de aula porque
esses dados conforme os alunos respondem
tudo isso vai sendo colocou coletado e
vai jogar num banco de dados o que
acontece tudo bem você siga adiante mas
o sistema sabe que aqueles 10%
então estão com dificuldade daquela
matéria então você pode depois tabular
aquilo ali e fazia um direcionamento
específico para aquele 10% ea luz
mandando materiais complementares
leituras complementares para aqueles 10%
de alunos
agora imagine se esse material que é
enviado para esses alunos ele é
produzido colaborativamente pelos
professores que compartilham materiais a
um like dislike desse material então
você consegue dentro de uma linguagem
mais atual saber qual o material é
melhor de forma que cada aluno possa ter
a sua tarde on line de didática
quem está falando sobre a amizade da ti
que hoje só tem um lado do facebook você
pode ter um time lá em didática em que
eu vou olhar minha timeline de materiais
e de sugestões pedagógicas que não são
necessariamente apostilas são são
palestras do ted
são vídeos do youtube são são livres da
wikipédia que complementam aquele
material conforme o desempenho dele em
sala de aula a partir das informações
coletadas com a resposta no celular
então nós estamos encaminhando para uma
época e que se vai ter um uma coisa que
é possível é possível fazer um
acompanhamento muito próximo do que está
acontecendo em cada aluno em cada
momento em cada sala de aula outros
setores já descobriram isso netflix faz
isso eles ou recomenda-lhe breve filme
pra você a amazon faz isso recomenda
compra pra você mas é está na hora a
gente fazia isso à educação também como
quero fechar a apresentação com três
mensagens principais primeiro a gente
tem que com a discussão além do
construtivismo essa discussão é
importante mas ela tem que além disso
sendo que para as técnicas processos
metodologias existe ciência no
aprendizado
então existem coisas que funcione coisas
que não funcionam eo terceiro a
tecnologia nossa parceira não é nossa
inimiga
então queria agradecer a todos obrigado